hello yes  michael  what have you done i was trying to help  people  but the cure  it's curse  i have powers that can only be described  as superhumans  but there's a cost  now a face of choice it's a hunt  and consume blood  or die  you all have monsters within us  it's up to us to control it  what if i can't  michael morbius  you've been given a gift  not exactly  time to let go of what you used to be  discover who you're meant to be  all our lives we've lived with death why  shouldn't they know what it feels like  for a change  just accept who you are  the bad guy  more bs  holy water really  yeah you ever see lost boys story of my  life  a new marvel legend arrives exclusively  in movie theaters april 1st